It's time for some jumping!
I have a feeling I'm not going to like this challenge!
Nice jump Miikka!
What are laughing?
Was that a jump?
That was not a jump!
I don't think that was a jump!
At least the other leg was in the air!
This is golden
He did an extra jump!
Yes!
What are those shots?
So tough!
Yea I think it was fun but...
Not for me!
Challenge: "Play ping pong to the tune of Mario"
How do we do it after that?
Ah yes, faster.
I think we got it now!
I think that was it!
Yea I think we got it!
So you might have seen Bruce Lee
play ping pong with nunchucks
We have been watching YouTube tutorials all morning
Hopefully we will get at least one shot on
By the way
If you're a creator or just enjoy making videos
Go and check out Epidemic Sound
We have been using their music in
all of our videos for the past year
And it's been really helpful
There is a free 30-day trial
In the link in our description
Go and try it out!
Now, to the nunchucks!
It's good control
I'm literally scared to be here
So is Otto
Backhand was going better
When it hits, it really hits hard!
And guys!
We post something new every week
So if you haven't subscribed yet
Do it now so you don't miss out!
Almost a jackpot!
Another one, another one!
Come on Otto!
Only one in a row
Karate kid
Went for it
Almost a jackpot!
That actually hurts quite bad
Okay let's continue!
I was like: it's hanging there, come back!
Well, two!
That's pretty good!
And guys remember to try out Epidemic Sound
Even if you only use the free
30-day trial
You will still be supporting our channel
Until next time!
Double nunchucks!
This is good!
We need at least one hit!
It's like: backspin, topspin, backspin,
topspin...
Don't try this at home!